okay so here's a funny story many years
ago
i received this and it's the little
trophy for 100
000 subscribers on youtube and what
happened was that i ticked over 100
000 subscribers on my channel but you
didn't get this
immediately what happened was some time
passed because youtube
was verifying that i really deserved
this award i assumed they wanted to
check that i hadn't just set up
100 000 extra youtube accounts and then
subscribed to myself
so that process took a little while but
eventually they then sent me a
notification said hey
congratulations give us an address and
we'll send this to you
so some of you might know recently i hit
a million subscribers which is kind of
mind-blowing and amazing
and i figured a similar thing would
happen before i would receive
this and much to my surprise it didn't
i got no notification like days and
weeks passed i thought huh that's kind
of bizarre but
no big deal maybe a million youtube
accounts takes longer to check and so i
didn't really worry about it too much
but little did i know that actually the
reason why that notification
never appeared was because youtube
unbeknownst to me was behind the scenes
actually arranging for me
to receive this in like a little
presentation with my students
teachers who i work with my principal as
well and they also like i have now all
these trust issues because
none of these people told me they kept a
very good secret had all these people
uh put together this wonderful little
compilation video of people being very
kind and saying lovely things
to celebrate the 1 million subscribers
so i want to say a big thank you
to all of the people who contributed to
that it was very
sweet thank you to all of my students in
the room who have to put up with me
always recording everything
thank you to the 1 million of you out
there who've decided that
these videos are something worthwhile
for you to spend your time on i hope
they've helped you learn
and also of course a massive thanks to
youtube who's really brought us all
together
and made this this learning and and this
channel
possible in the first place so the video
that they ended up producing for me and
showing to me in class
when i received the trophy is what
you're about to watch
right now so enjoy
hi eddie wu congratulations on getting
one million
on youtube congratulations eddie
i just want to say a massive
congratulations for hitting one
million subscribers eddie you totally
deserve it for all the amazing work you
do for education
because remember the length is x right
[Applause]
i love how you channel your passion for
math
[Music]
it's kind of funny to talk about why i
love maths because i didn't love maths
when i was at school
congratulations for reaching one million
youtube subscribers that's simply
amazing
[Music]
congratulations eddie on 1 million
subscribers more videos for advanced
extension in the newsletters has
definitely helped me
along with a lot of other students and
these are these rings of the onion
are also concentric what you do online
next level sensational keep making a
difference you have made such
a difference has definitely influenced
the way i would like to execute my
lessons
i'm so inspired by you congratulations
thank you for setting the bar so high
you